Hi zusammen!
Wir machen heute eine neue Folge "Wie vom Bäcker".
Es gibt ja schon einige Rezepte, bei denen ich Dinge nachmache,
die dann so schmecken wie vom Bäcker, also so die Klassiker.
Kann ich euch meine Playlist hier unten verlinken und wir machen heute Käsebrötchen wie vom Bäcker.
Die könnt ihr zum Frühstück snacken, mit in die Uni nehmen, die Schule,
mit zur Arbeit oder einfach weil ihr Bock drauf habt!
(H: Früher jeden Morgen vor der Schule!)
Ich auch!
(H: Oder nach der Schule!)
Käsebrötchen waren voll mein Ding.
Meine Mutter hat mir immer Käsebrötchen gekauft
wenn sie es nicht geschafft hat, mir ein Brot zu schmieren.
Und wenn sie ein Brot geschmiert hat, dann gab's immer Frischkäse.
(H: Weißt du, was ich immer gemocht habe? Ich weiß nicht, ob du's auch schaffst,
aber immer diese Kruste am Rand!)
Ja, siggi!
Hallo, die Kruste war das beste!
(H: That's my girl!)
Ja Mann! So, wir fangen jetzt direkt an.
Die ganz genauen Mengenangaben stehen unten in der Videobeschreibung.
Ich starte jetzt direkt. Ich habe hier ganz normales Mehl Typ 405,
da gebe ich jetzt Salz rein. Ich gebe auch Zucker dazu, Zucker hebt auch nochmal den Geschmack
und rundet das Ganze schön ab falls ihr euch wundert warum.
Dann nehme ich heute Trockenhefe, ihr könntet auch frische Hefe nehmen.
Falls ihr frische Hefe benutzt, dann müsst ihr das vorab mit dem lauwarmem Wasser verrühren.
Ich muss das jetzt nicht. In meinen Teig kommen jetzt erst die trockenen Zutaten.
Ein bisschen verrühren mit dem Schneebesen
und jetzt mache ich mit den Händen weiter. Ich benutze auch extra nicht die Küchenmaschine
damit Leute, die keine Küchenmaschine dahaben, sehen, wie einfach das geht.
So, jetzt habe ich hier lauwarmes Wasser,
dann gebe ich da Öl dazu und dann wird verknetet.
So, jetzt habe ich den Teig 4-5 min lang mit den Händen erst in der Schüssel,
dann auf der Arbeitsfläche durchgeknetet.
Und ihr merkt auch: der ist mega geschmeidig, der klebt überhaupt nicht!
Ich forme ihn jetzt so halbwegs zu einer Kugel und dann gebe ich ihn zurück in die Schüssel.
Die werde ich jetzt ein bisschen fetten weil ich jetzt einfach nicht noch mehr Mehl möchte
damit der Teig auch geschmeidig bleibt und nicht austrocknet.
Ich nehme jetzt hier mein Back - ups! Mein Backspray *lacht*
oben auf die Oberfläche, das ist sogar noch wichtiger.
So ihr Lieben. Jetzt zugedeckt 45min lang ruhen lassen.
Der Teig sollte dann schön aufgehen und dann geht's schon weiter
und das ist ein wirklich sehr schnelles Rezept, daher wird das Video galub ich mal nicht so lange gehen, ne?
(H: Ich denke mal nicht!)
Okay, bis gleich!
So, nach der Ruhezeit nehmen wir uns den Teig auf die Arbeitsfläche
und teilen ihnen mit der Teigkarte durch 6
und dann könnt ihr es direkt auf das Backblech tun, ich habe das Backblech vorher eingefettet.
Wichtig ist, dass ihr euren Teig zu Kugeln rollt und auf dem Backblech nochmal ganz leicht andrückt.
Und so müssen sie jetzt noch mal ruhen. Die Entspannung ist sehr sehr wichtig bei dem Teig
damit er später auch richtig schön gut schmeckt und fluffig wird.
So, jetzt decke ich das noch mal zu, diesmal nur 15min
und dann bestreiche ich die Teiglinge mit Ei und bestreue sie mit Käse, mit reichlich Käse!
Die Käsebrötchen werden jetzt im vorgeheizten Backofen bei 180° C Ober- und Unterhitze
für ca 18min gebacken.
Und wenn ihr sie schön weich lassen wollt, also schön weich beibehalten möchtet,
dann am besten direkt in einem Stoffbeutel verpacken.
Also Hauptsache in irgendwas luftdichtem damit sie nicht austrocknen
Weil so sind sie jetzt noch mega mega weich und noch warm!
Und ich mag immer, erstmal außen die Kruste hier abzumachen und zu essen
und dann esse ich das ganze Brötchen!
Ich mach' mal auf..
(H: Zeig mal, zeig mal, zeig mal!)
So sieht's aus. Also genauso mag ich den Teig,
schön saftig, bei mir kommt ja immer Öl mit rein bei Käsebrötchen.
Und ich lasse es mir jetzt einfach mal schmecken! Das ist tatsächlich mein Mittagessen.
Vielleicht mache ich mir noch was dazu..
(H: Du hast einfach meinen Traum erfüllt,
Käsebrötchen zuhause machen!)
Ja, Käsebrötchen..also ich mach' die nur noch zuhause, seit Jahren schon!
(H: Also ich hab's auch noch nie gegessen von meiner Mama oder so!)
Echt?
(H: Meine Mama hat auch nie Käsebrötchen alleine gemacht,
also nicht dass ich wüsste!)
Aha!
(H: Und?)
Erzähl weiter, ich ess' solange!
(H: *lacht*)
Unbedingt nachmachen, richtig richtig lecker!)
(H: Zu Ende gegessen?)
Jetzt hab ich zu Ende gegessen,
Jetzt kommt noch ein richtiges Outro! Also ganz viel Freude beim Nachmachen,
Hinterlasst mir unbedingt ein kostenloses Abo falls ihr's noch nicht schon längst getan habt
und bitte bitte schreibt mir in die Kommentare, welches Rezept ich "wie vom Bäcker"
als nächstes für euch nachmachen soll, dann mache ich mich da ran!
Und wir lassen uns das jetzt schmecken und dann wünsche ich euch noch einen wunderschönen Tag!
Bis zum nächsten Mal auf Kikis Kitchen, Tschüss!